star fox
the royal prince
of titan brother of thanos what do you
want lads
your friends are in big trouble and we
know where to find them
welcome back everyone this is going to
be my eternals deleted scene video for
harry styles star fox thanos and the
alternate ending to the movie that they
just revealed which was going to
originally be way way darker than the
ending we got in the theatrical cut so
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs if
you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos i do
marvel videos every week but they just
released eternals on disney plus in a
whole bunch of deleted scenes so a lot
of you probably been rewatching the post
credit scenes and bigger moments in the
theatrical version of the post-credits
scene harry styles and pat and oswalt
show up on the domo the eternal ship
here is star fox and pip the troll after
druid makari and thena have been
traveling through the universe for weeks
searching for response signals from the
other groups of eternals that were sent
to other celestial seed worlds in other
galaxies after introducing him as the
prince of titan brother of thanos star
fox reveals he's another prime maternal
just like ajax was and just like cersei
became with a special celestial core
that allows him to communicate directly
with irish and the judge and tells them
he knows what happened to the other
eternals he knows the irish and the
judge came to earth to take them back to
the world forge and he knows where to
find the world forge that's the place
where airshim the judge created all the
eternals and all the deviants but they
just revealed way more deleted scenes
with star fox and originally they had a
bunch of extra backstory for him
explaining his character his
relationship with thanos tying in more
with the backstory for titan that we got
during avengers infinity war that
explains what happened to titan and why
it got destroyed and the darker ending
sort of ties in with what they were
doing with these extra hairy style
scenes like an empire strikes back
avengers infinity war style ending with
a really hardcore downer moment so i'll
start with the deleted star fox scenes
first in the thanos titan backstory
stuff and then i'll talk about the
alternate ending but in the deleted
scenes star fox is seen with the other
eternals while they're dressed in their
base layers before they've been sent to
a new celestial seed world the silver or
grayish robes that they all wear when
they're being rebooted and their minds
are being wiped this is basically what
they look like between missions like
they've been doing this for millions of
years going around to different galaxies
different celestial seed worlds birthing
new celestials and after each new
celestial is born no matter which group
of eternals you're talking about which
galaxy you're talking about they all go
back to their ship and they go back to
these base layer robes and get rebooted
they go into hibernation as they're sent
to another world salma hayak actually
revealed that she was here filming these
scenes with harry styles when they were
dressed in these robes it sounds like
they filmed more flashbacks for harry
styles character to explain his story
when he shows up in this version the
theatrical cut but also another version
of the ending where harry styles is with
them when they're all being sent to
another planet to birth another
celestial and we would have seen harry
styles star fox with his original group
of eternals traveling to titan in more
scenes of him with younger thanos and
the other eternals that were part of his
group of eternals the director explained
that star fox was originally part of a
group of 10 eternals that were sent to
titan by heirs from the judge because
it's always a group of ten like that's
why they start with this group of
eternals and there are 10 of them before
ajax gets killed so star fox's group of
10 eternals were sent to titan because
titan was another celestial seed world
the director didn't say which celestial
was inside titan but that was the idea
and he also rebelled against his group's
mission just like cersei and the other
main group of eternals in this movie do
except he was not successful in saving
titan he fled the planet before it was
destroyed rebelling against irishman the
judge i know it sounds like there's some
conflicting information between the
story thanos told about what happened to
titan and what they were going to say
happened during the eternals movie but
in all these alternate star fox scenes
it's implied that the emergence on titan
was the reason it was destroyed i think
that thanos story about overpopulation
in avengers infinity war fits with the
eternal's true mission to drive
overpopulation in order to speed up the
emergence if you think about it that way
it's not as much of a continuity issue
each celestial needs to feed off a
certain amount of cosmic energy given
off by life on planets so the more
people the faster that happens in thanos
said that he wanted to kill half the
population on titan to prevent that from
happening so the idea is that thanos
also probably learned about the
emergence on titan and tried to stop it
by getting rid of half the people
you're not the only one cursed with
knowledge so this is a new way of
contextualizing thanos plan to balance
half the universe it makes him seem like
more of an anti-hero than a total
villain like getting rid of half the
population to stop the celestials from
creating more celestials and i think
that's why star fox also didn't try to
stop thanos earlier from snapping half
of all life with the infinity gauntlet
like if star fox is another prime
eternal with this celestial core it
means he's crazy powerful but if star
fox also rebelled against airship the
judge the way they explained in this
movie he also wouldn't have wanted to
stop thanos because it sounds like
thanos also had this grand plan to stop
the celestials it's just that thanos was
going about it in the most hardcore dark
way possible i did a longer video about
how the eternals movie recontextualizes
thanos's plan making him seem like more
of a hero so i had a link for that in
the description below but the alternate
ending the downer version of the ending
that the director said she originally
wanted to use started with the eternals
failing to stop the emergence on earth
like tiamet would have successfully been
born burst out of the earth destroying
everything all the remaining eternals
would have survived and ajax would have
somehow survived or been repaired by
heirs from the judge and the movie would
have ended with them back in these gray
robes being rebooted and sent to another
celestial seed planet and the cycle
would have started again and it seems
like they also shot a version of that
downer ending with them being rebooted
again with harry styles star fox
character with them the reasons why i
think marvel didn't want to use that
version of the ending is one because
it's super depressing and two it would
have raised too many questions about the
continuity because how could they
destroy earth and still say this was the
main mcu universe it would only make
sense if the events of the movie were
happening in an alternate universe and
the eternals movie wasn't supposed to be
a big multiverse plot the way spider-man
no way home and doctor strange
multiverse of madness are multiverse
movies there's just way too many cosmic
concepts and new mythology with the
celestials in the black knight that they
were introducing in the film and the
eternals movie is supposed to take place
after the events of the shangshi movie
which itself takes place around the time
spider-man is getting doxxed by mysterio
in spider-man far from home like later
in 2023 so the events of spider-man no
way home in hawkeye are currently the
latest we've been the furthest forward
we've been in the marvel phase four
timeline because they both end around
christmas 2024 if that wasn't clear if
you do want to count the loki series yes
they do travel to the end of the
timeline like billions of years in the
future but all this stuff at the end of
the eternals movie is happening around
the time that spider-man no way home is
picking up and there aren't really any
easter eggs for that during spider-man
no way home like you have to imagine on
the other side of the planet while this
is getting started there's this giant
stone celestial showing up in the indian
ocean like wait a minute what you have
to imagine jay jonah jameson would be
trying to blame timid on spider-man
somehow he would find some way to blame
spider-man for that and a lot of you
have also asked how star fox and thanos
can be brothers and the sons of a large
and sweet san on titan if they're all
eternals and all eternals are just
celestial robots who can't have children
and how did star fox become the prime
eternal of their groupon titans
[Music]
so just based on all these deleted
scenes and story lines that they've
revealed they imply that airshim the
judge created star fox group of eternals
all 10 of them together including thanos
so the mcu version of thanos and star
fox were probably not born biologically
the children of allars and sweet sand
the way they were in the comics in their
family in the same way that all the
eternals think of each other as a
hodgepodge family of sorts like the
eternals that we see during the movie
all think of each other as family but
they're not biologically related i think
the red skull scene from avengers
infinity war where he's greeting thanos
and gamora actually backs this up
because he says gamora daughter of
thanos and she was not born to thanos
like he was her adoptive father so when
he says thanos son of a lars in the mcu
at least it's a little bit different and
he's not saying that they're
biologically related i think they
probably just changed that part of their
backstory just in the name of simplicity
for mcu continuity purposes the reason
why thanos looks like purple space
grimace with the nutsack chin different
from all the other eternals from titan
is because he carries the deviant
mutation but he's not a deviant himself
he's another eternal that just looks
different in the mcu the way they
explain this is that all the eternals
are created to look similar to the
beings that inhabit the celestial seed
worlds that they get sent to they're
just created to blend in with whatever
populations they go to so that's why
fastos looks different from makari for
instance all the others why they all
speak with different accents they were
just created to blend in when they get
rebooted and sent to a new planet
they're just sort of reprogrammed to
blend in with whatever population is on
that planet so for instance if a group
of eternals was sent to the scroll
homeworld or a world in the scroll
empire the eternals would look like
scrolls and based on star fox's
backstory they implied that thanos
rebelled against their eternal's mission
first like he learned about the truth of
the emergence first on titan and was
banished by alars after he tried to get
them to kill half the population to stop
the emergence
you're not the only one cursed with
knowledge then after he was gone
something happened to a large he also
died and then naming star fox his
successor passing his celestial court to
him and that's how star fox would have
become the prime eternal of his group on
titan taking over their emergence
mission but then also himself eventually
rebelling against irish and the judge
and escaping the same way that cersei
rebelled after she got the celestial
core from ajax in the next time he shows
up in a movie harry styles shows up as
star fox like during eternals 2 if they
do a sequel or some other mcu space
based movie they'll cover more of his
backstory with thanos on titan so
eventually they will tell the rest of
that story for those of you that want to
see more of young thanos like the
thinner version of thanos we can call
him thinos but if you have any other
questions about star fox and thanos just
write them below in the comments i might
do another video about the celestials in
the cosmic history of the mcu now that
the movies come out so if you have any
other video requests or any other big
cosmic questions about the mcu just
write them below in the comments too
everyone click here for that new
eternals black knight deleted scene for
kid harrington's character and click
here to learn how thanos save the
avengers from the celestials thank you
so much for watching everyone stay safe
and i'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]